Un día más os traemos un vídeo reaccionando a vuestras opiniones impopulares.
Y decimos impopulares porque en realidad deberíamos decir de mi...
Un momento, un momento, antes de que arranque el vídeo dejadme contaros que se acerca un nuevo viaje de la media inglesa
al fin de semana del 18 y 19 de octubre.
Viajamos a Inglaterra para vivir en directo un nuevo partido del Harvard Tank como hicimos la temporada pasada.
Por solo 289 euros que incluye todo el fin de semana.
El viernes saldremos desde Londres en autobús hacia Leicester.
Esa noche ya estaremos ahí en Leicester tomando unas cervecillas.
Sábado haremos un tour por Leicester por la mañana.
Nos iremos a Harvard para ver el partido y vivir el tercer tiempo con los muchachos.
Y por la noche, sábado por la noche en Leicester, los que hayan venido a otros viajes ya saben lo que les espera.
Y domingo regreso a Londres.
¿Qué incluyen esos 289 euros?
Lo que no incluyen son los vuelos, pero sí que incluyen todos los traslados en autobús, dos noches de hotel, desayuno y por supuesto la entrada al partido.
Con el enlace que tenéis aquí abajo podéis comprar ya vuestro viaje para acompañarnos,
para ir juntos con toda la comunidad de la media inglesa a vivir este partido el sábado 18 de octubre.
Os esperamos.
Hay días, Pablo, bautizos, comuniones y bodas en los que uno se tiene que vestir bien.
Hoy es el caso porque me he puesto la camiseta de mi querido Aro deportivo.
Increíble.
Porque mi hermano Dani, el presidente del Aro deportivo me lo ha hecho llegar y estoy orgulloso.
Pesic dijo que hay dos cosas que me faltan en mi vida, mi familia y mi Yugoslavia.
A ti hasta el día de hoy te faltaban dos cosas y una era el Aro deportivo.
Un pincel la madre que me parió.
De Aro.
Visitar Aro y el Aro deportivo.
De Aro es luz de la fuente.
Luz de la fuente.
Hombre que le ha estrechado la mano más de una vez a mi hermano Dani.
Es una estrechada de manos que genera onda expansiva.
Alí muy cercano a mí vio a luz de la fuente hace nada.
Un mes, mes y medio, eso es donde le vio.
En un sitio donde te lo esperas y te vio con Aro.
En una bodega.
En una bodega de vinos estaba luz de la fuente haciendo la visita con el resto de la gente.
El luz de la fuente va a saber mucho de vinos.
Va a agarrar muy bien la copa, ese tipo de cosas.
Y desde fútbol, vinos y gym.
Y ya está.
Luz de la fuente al final es el sueño de los pibes.
Y España.
España, coño, el mejor campeón de Europa.
Pues nada amigos, dicho esto vamos a ir con nuestro vídeo de opiniones impopulares.
Porque os hemos pedido opiniones impopulares y estas son las que nos habéis hecho llegar.
La edición número 11.
Queríamos hacer uno al mes y hemos hecho 11 en casi dos años.
Así que bueno, no lo estamos cumpliendo.
Es un vídeo que os gusta mucho y aquí os lo traemos.
Os ha elegido chozas y nosotros lo vamos a leer por sorpresa.
Las hemos cogido tanto de Discord como de Twitter.
Así que bueno, siempre avisaremos por esos dos canales.
Por si nos queréis mandar alguna.
Albert 8 nos dice.
Te pregunto, ¿es esto impopular?
Porque creo que esto lo piensa muchísima gente.
Creo que lo impopular es lo que pienso yo y creo que lo que piensas tú.
Yo sigo pensando que mientras Arteta
siga dando saltos de nivel cada temporada,
merece seguir en el cargo.
Dio saltos de nivel evidentes en la Premier League las tres últimas temporadas.
El año pasado sí que es verdad que no dio el salto de nivel en la Premier League,
pero lo dio en Europa.
Un equipo que venía de hace nada competir Europa League
y de no competir por la Champions League,
eliminó al Real Madrid metiéndolo un 5-1 en el Global
y estuvo a punto de eliminar también al PSG en las semifinales.
¿Cuál es el problema?
Que ya el siguiente paso tanto en Premier como en Europa es ganar.
Entonces creo que al menos hay que darle este año
porque Arteta, a pesar de no levantar ningún título,
siempre ha ido mejorando sus resultados,
ya sea en Liga o Champions o en Liga y Champions.
Hay un argumento que usa el propio Miquel Arteta,
que es que en los últimos tres años el Arsenal es el que más puntos ha acumulado
en la Premier League.
Me parece que es un argumento que no sirve para justificar
la falta de trofeos,
pero en mi opinión sí sirve para dar continuidad al proyecto,
porque considero que es la manera de pensar que estás muy cerca de conseguirlo,
que te estás manteniendo muy cerca de conseguirlo
y que estás en la senda para conseguirlo.
¿Eso significa que lo vas a conseguir?
Pues no lo sé, porque te has encontrado con un Manchester City
y con un Liverpool de dimensión histórica en cuanto a sus puntuaciones.
Pero a mí eso sí me justifica que el proyecto en un año bueno,
en el que levanta el pie el acelerador,
porque también eso tiene que suceder,
algunos de tus rivales directos ganarás el título y yo,
si fuese director deportivo, me haría pensar que prefiero quedarme con Arteta,
que me está manteniendo en esa zona,
antes que considero que estoy cerca de conseguirlo,
que probar con otra cosa nueva.
Ahora, pues tampoco sé qué decir,
luego a lo mejor cambias de entrenador y te hacen...
Es un caso completamente diferente,
te llega un túgel y de repente revoluciona el equipo
y te gana la premia en la primera.
Bueno, pero...
O es Lotko en el Liverpool, que parecía que con Klopp ya no...
Pero bueno, de todas maneras es el que decía exactamente.
¿Qué no es el entrenador capacitado para llevarlo al siguiente nivel?
Bueno, si el siguiente nivel, el ganar la premia o la Champions,
creo que hay muy pocos entrenadores en el mundo capacitados para hacer eso,
eso vaya por delante,
pero tampoco puedo hablar de lo que no he visto.
Esto ya es imaginarme lo que puede llegar a ser Arteta,
pero no te puedo decir que sea capaz de no hacerlo.
Aprovechando que lo tenemos por aquí...
Yo sí me quedaría con Arteta, por lo que os he dicho.
La leche, que tenemos el libreto del partido del Arsenal-Real Madrid,
que fueron chozas e hílias,
parece que iba a ser un partido sin más y acabo siendo historia.
En este partido, en las faltas de Declan Rice,
lo estoy diciendo de memoria,
pero el Arsenal se metió después de la vuelta en el Bernabéu
por tercera vez en una semifinales de Champions.
Es que Miquel Arteta sigue dando pasos históricos con el Arsenal.
Yo sí tengo la sensación de que es un club que sigue hacia adelante
y en lo que es más importante, que no se está cayendo.
Que en situarse en primera línea para pelear por los títulos
no se está cayendo.
Me parece perfectamente también lícito que alguien piense,
pues no es suficiente, después de tanto tiempo.
Ya tenemos que estar ganando algo.
Bueno, creo que este año...
A la hora de, en el debate de cambiar ya Arteta o no,
yo no estoy ahí.
Creo que este va a ser el año de todas formas,
por lo que decíamos, que ya la siguiente mejora en Champions
o en Premier es ganar.
Entonces veremos si este año es el último de Arteta,
porque no hemos sido un título,
o el que ya Arteta consiga el título.
Mi pregunta es, Pablo,
¿echas a Arteta si pierde la Premier League sumando 85 puntos?
Este para mí es el debate.
Necesito contexto de qué han pasado en las Copas y en Champions.
Si en Champions terminan en cuarto...
85 puntos y cuartos de Champions.
Fuera.
Yo en ese caso, por ejemplo, creo que no lo echaría,
porque creo que sigo estando cerca del objetivo
y que el equipo no se haya desplomado.
85 puntos me parece una muy buena puntuación.
Pero esta plantilla del Arsenal ya me parece que es de 85.
Una cosa sí es, 85 puntos, cuartos de Champions,
y luego ganas CF y Cup, lo mantengo.
Que a ver, que luego hay que entender el contexto.
A lo mejor es una plantilla que en las últimas diez jornadas
se ha desplomado.
Pero para mí, pero para mí esta plantilla...
En este sentido, tendría miedo a equivocarme con el reemplazo,
porque creo que te sigue manteniendo en una zona
que muy pocos entrenadores consigue mantener de una forma tan regular.
Yo creo que esta plantilla ya te exige los 85 puntos.
Pasamos al siguiente tema, que también es del Arsenal.
Dice, Zou...
Zoumera Cavado.
Dice, Benger está muy sobrevalorado.
Sólo ganó tres ligas en 22 años y cero títulos europeos,
teniendo en cuenta que tuvo a grandes jugadores.
Pues, si nos fijamos en la palabra que utiliza,
que es sobrevalorado,
creo que al menos en Inglaterra lo está.
No digo que no tenga una importancia brutal
en cambiar el fútbol inglés,
no digo que no tenga una importancia brutal
en cambiar la historia del Arsenal,
la historia moderna del Arsenal,
y no digo que no sea uno de los top 6, top 7,
mejores entrenadores de la historia de la Premier.
Pero creo que se le pone...
Ferguson Benger Guardiola,
ya es como el top 3 histórico de entrenadores de la Premier League,
y en para mí, Klopp o Mourinho están por delante de Benger.
Es cierto que es una persona muy innovadora
y cambió a nivel alimentación, hábitos, entrenamiento, ciencia,
cambió el fútbol inglés.
Pero sí que es verdad que sus últimos años son muy malos.
Y cuando voy luego a los títulos finales,
Benger me pierde con Klopp o me pierde con Mourinho.
Yo lo pongo por encima de...
De Klopp, lo pongo a la misma altura que Mourinho.
Mourinho...
O sea, lo estoy hablando en clave Premier.
Yo también en clave Premier en general.
Evidentemente, la carrera luego de Mourinho...
Hombre, a mí los títulos que ha conseguido en otros equipos
y a nivel incluso europeo,
pero estoy hablando en clave Premier si lo pongo en un mismo escalón.
Pero es que sí coincido, pero no sé si están...
No sé si están así todavía.
Me parece que hay un espacio reservado para Ferguson, Guardiola, Klopp...
Como si fueran tiers, digamos,
yo los colocaría en esa altura por encima de Benger.
Ahora bien...
Claro, es que también estoy hablando...
A ver, en clave Premier me refiero no solo fijándome en Premier,
sino en lo que has hecho en Inglaterra.
Al final, ¿qué es lo que nos hemos visto mal?
Quiero decir que no me entendáis que estoy viendo solo las Premier Leagues.
No.
Ahora bien...
Benger creo que...
de todos es el que se encuentra un equipo y una época
en la que es más difícil cambiar.
O sea, Benger, lo que yo creo que también se valora,
y que yo al menos valoro,
es que muchas de las cosas que pasan después
y que a Benger le superan o le pasan por encima,
precisamente tienen origen en Benger.
Sin Benger, el fútbol inglés hoy no se entiende tal y como lo conocemos.
Hay una corriente aperturista en todos los sentidos,
pero también incluso a la hora de internacionalizar el fútbol inglés,
que tiene que ver con Benger.
Y a veces, entre comillas, que se me entienda,
pero que Benger acaba siendo un poco víctima
de la misma escuela que él introduce en el país.
Y eso a mí como pionero, yo le doy mucho valor.
Haber ganado esa Liga invicto,
evidentemente sé que hay otros equipos
que hicieron muchos más puntos que los ganners,
pero ganó esa Liga invicto.
Y creo además que ganar esas ligas
con un dominio tan establecido del Manchester United,
con la irrupción además paulatina del Chelsea,
le doy un mérito como para acercarlo a ese tier,
pero les dejo por detrás de esos tres.
Ahora, mi duda es si eso significa que está sobrevalorado
porque la gente no opina lo que acabamos de decir.
Yo creo que el amante del fútbol inglés,
sobre todo el más nostálgico,
sigue pensando que Benger, Ferguson y luego vienen todos los demás.
Yo creo que eso ya no.
Pero es que bueno, es un debate también.
A mí Guardiola me parece que es indiscutible en el primer tier,
pero bueno, pues también hay quien le achaca a él
los pecados del Manchester City en cuanto a los cargos
por los que está acusado por la Premier League.
Quiero decir que es un debate que ya tiene tanta mezcla de...
Es difícil.
Claro, hay gente que no le concede a Klopp este galardón
porque solo tiene una Premier League,
que no lo compro tampoco.
Klopp ha hecho puntuaciones que en cualquier otra temporada
habrían sido campeones durante varios años.
Estuvo nueve años o diez.
Y quien se lo ganó fue Guardiola, que lo estoy poniendo en ese primer tier.
No sé.
Para terminar con la pregunta, ¿está sobrevalorado?
Yo creo que está en su justa medida.
No tengo la sensación de que a estas alturas de la vida
ya tanta gente diga Ferguson, Benger y luego el resto.
Puede ser.
Es mi sensación.
La siguiente me flipa.
Porque nunca la había pensado y por eso me gustan tanto estos vídeos.
Porque nos proponeis debates que no se me habían ocurrido.
Luque Girón, Bruno Fernández,
es top tres mediocentros del Manchester United en la era Premier.
Solo King y Scholes lo superan.
Ni Beckham ni Carrick hubieran hecho tanto como Bruno
en el contexto en el que él ha jugado.
Me encanta porque yo estoy muy convencido
que Bruno Fernández es el mejor futbolista del United post-Ferberson,
desde 2013.
Pero nunca había pensado si es top tres también mediocentros
en la era Premier League.
Con de Gea.
Hombre, David de Gea.
Sí, sí, sí, con de Gea.
Vale, sí, con de Gea, pero me da tanta pena Bruno
que igual estoy siendo injusto con el español.
Me parece que hay debate, no?
Me parece una cosa muy clara.
Que lo pongo un poco por encima.
Por mencionar a David de Gea.
Top tres.
A ver, Scholes es más, Roy Keane es más.
Creo que está claro.
No es ni siquiera siglo XXI, es en la era Premier, desde el 92.
Claro, había que meter también a los Paulins,
había que meter también a Beckham, a Carrick.
Roy Keane, no te aguantas este Manchester United.
No te aguantas este Manchester United ni de broma.
Mira que me gustaba Roy Keane.
De lo que...
Porque yo ahí sí que no soy tan contemporáneo de Roy Keane.
Beckham, Carrick, o sea, están Beckham, Carrick, Paulins.
Verón, que evidentemente no entra,
pero por decir centro campistas míticos.
No, yo te diría que...
Yo te diría que después de Scholes tiene argumentos.
Tiene argumentos para debatirle a...
O sea, Roy Keane, el tema está que evidentemente
es un líder absoluto de un Manchester United ultracampeón,
pero el contexto es completamente diferente al de Bruno Fernández.
Yo ya sabes que siempre he usado el término de superviviente con él.
Me parece que tiene un mérito extraordinario que en un Manchester
United caído a trozos deportivamente, él siguiera
rindiendo un nivel de estrella.
Entonces yo lo puedo comprar.
Yo lo compro.
Que después de Scholes...
O sea, por ejemplo, Bruno, antes que Beckham,
no tengo problema y Beckham me parece un extraordinario futbolista,
pero yo valoro mucho cómo Bruno
ha andado contracorriente con el viento soplando siempre en su contra.
Michael Carrick, a ver, es que ya empezamos a hablar de jugadores muy diferentes.
Michael Carrick, de hecho, a mí lo que más me duele es no haberlo visto
en la época actual.
Carrick creo que habría sido un centro campista para el fútbol de
de los 2010, 2020 increíble.
Y Paul Scholes más de lo mismo.
Sí, sería todavía mejor.
Pero sí, te puedo comprar que después de Scholes
es que de verdad que lo pongo a ese nivel porque estoy intentando separarlo.
Sé que me estoy metiendo con leyendas del club, auténticas leyendas.
Beckham es clave en la temporada del triplete en el 99.
Pero es que creo que Bruno Fernández tiene el nivel para también
puede ser clave en una temporada de un triplete actual.
Yo me voy a poner, me lo voy a poner por debajo de Scholes y de Keane.
Yo también.
Por encima de Beckham y con Carrick tengo esa duda
porque Carrick siempre lo consigo muy fralorado.
Pero pero venga.
Yo yo solo compro.
Yo solo compro lo que giron.
Me parece.
Creo que cuando se vaya al Manchester United, sea cuando sea,
se merece que sea considerado una gran leyenda de la era
Premier League del Manchester United, como si veas.
Y quiero decir que se queda un Monte Rushmore muy raro.
Con todo época de Ferguson y de repente de G.A.
y Bruno dices coño, estos que hacen aquí.
Y que la gente del Manchester United lo vea y diga
es que este tío en las malas fue el que muchas veces nos acaba el pozo.
Es que no es tan locura decir que es igual el Manchester United
sin Bruno Fernández el año pasado pelea por el descenso.
O sea, es esa la situación tan grave el Manchester United.
Y creo que le han venido muy bien, aunque sean dos títulos menores,
la FECUP no tanto, FECUP y la Copa de la Liga.
El haber ganado ya esos dos títulos, además uno al Manchester City,
él levantándolo, creo que le hace un favor a su legado.
Vamos con Rodri, 21, que dice
¿Qué injusto es que Palmer haya acabado octavo en el Balón de Oro
por hacer un partidazo en la final del Mundial de Clubes?
Pero Caicedo, que para mí fue el mejor jugador del Chelsea a largo,
no estuviese ni entre los 30 primeros.
Bueno, por diseccionar un poco las dos cosas.
Que Caicedo no esté entre los 30 mejores jugadores del mundo
no tiene ningún tipo de sentido y solo explican dos razones.
Uno que es mediocentro defensivo y otro que es ecuatoriano.
Lo digo así de claro.
Si Caicedo llega a ser español, argentino, brasileño,
inglés, alemán, de una nacionalidad con más historia en el fútbol,
Caicedo hubiera sido top 30, seguro.
Porque ha sido...
¿Qué te diría? No, voy a jugar con el Chelsea,
conference, ya, pero y Palmer...
Pero está Palmer, por eso.
Es, Caicedo ha sido el mejor jugador del Chelsea la temporada pasada.
Y luego la posición tampoco le ayuda, él es el mediocentro defensivo.
A ver, bueno...
Me parece que es un puesto muy alto para Palmer.
Y es un puesto muy alto para Palmer.
Es una maravilla de futbolista, pero...
Bueno, es que está...
El puesto de Fabián ya me coloca todo lo demás.
Bueno, realmente Fabián, João Neves...
Sobre todo me tengo que fijar en el PSG.
Sí.
Pero no me coloca el resto de...
Tengo una opinión bastante más radical,
que es que el balón de oro debería dar el top 3.
Y ya está.
No me parece mal.
Porque me parece que ordenar tantos jugadores diferente...
O sea, Fabián ha hecho mejor temporada de Caicedo,
evidentemente, porque ha ganado el Champions,
pero ¿estás comparando a Fabián, que es otra liga,
ni siquiera ha competido en las mismas competiciones?
Es como en los tierleys, que cuando ya pones muchos futbolistas,
se te está olvidando hasta con qué les comparas.
O sea, ordenar del 3 al 30 es muy difícil.
Me parece que ahí sí que ya juega mucho más marketing,
expectación, se lo cargarían todo eso
y no puede vivir sin eso en la gala del balon...
Pues estoy de acuerdo, eh.
El podio.
Pondría un podio con balón de bronce, balón de plata,
balón de oréa, toma por saco.
Sí.
R1 05, o R105, si no sois tontos como yo,
que nos la deja en Discord, dice...
Túgel es un técnico normalito que se encontró al Chelsea
y ha vivido su carrera por él,
pero no es mejor que Tomás Frank o Frank Lampard.
Y no lo hemos puesto ni Nacho ni yo.
Hostias.
A ver, Túgel es mejor que Frank Lampard, chicos.
O sea, sabéis que nos encanta Frank Lampard,
pero Frank Lampard lo está haciendo bien en la segunda división
y lo hizo bien un año en el Chelsea.
¿Me se encontró al Chelsea?
O sea, nos encontró al Chelsea, resucitó al Chelsea de Frank Lampard.
Recuerdo además que en aquella...
Yo estaba trabajando en el diario,
a Asli hizo un artículo y no sé por qué se me quedó grabado ese dato
con Lampard, que se va en enero.
El Chelsea no había ganado nadie el top 10 de la Premier League.
Era un equipo muy, muy, muy flojo.
Lampard pone unas bases que siempre valoraré,
pero el Chelsea de Tomás Túgel era una obra táctica de primerísimo nivel.
Y cambia la formación, la forma de jugar.
No se encuentra nada.
De verdad, acordáos, lo difícil que era desenredar
lo que te planteaba el Chelsea de Tomás Túgel.
Puede que a veces no fuese el equipo de mayor fantasía futbolística
que teníamos en la tele,
pero era una obra de ingeniería ese equipo y que funcionaba como un reloj.
Lo dijo Pe Guardiola.
Y acabó desesperando, por ejemplo, a un Manchester City de Pe Guardiola
que era un misil de equipo.
Le dio para lo que le dio una Champions League con el Chelsea.
Bueno, una cosa, y dos finales.
Y dos finales, es verdad.
Fue un equipo de copero.
Que las dos has perdido contra el Liverpool de club en los penaltis.
Y porque Quimminke, el EG, con nueve años era delantero y metió unos penaltis.
Sí, pero bueno, que Tomás Túgel luego,
es verdad que en el PSG a nivel nacional es más habitual ganar,
pero llevo una final de la Champions también al PSG.
Sé que luego en el Bayern, la liga que gana,
todavía está el Borussia Dortmund preguntándose cómo la pierde.
Pero semifinales de Champions contra el Madrid,
que le remonta con José Luna el descuento.
Pero rozado otra Champions, otra final.
No puedo compararlo con Tomás Fanning o con Fran Lampard.
Ah, por favor.
Y eso que ya os digo, todo lo que ha hecho fuera del Chelsea,
mucho no me ha impresionado.
Tampoco he tenido oportunidad de seguirlo tanto.
Ahora con Inglaterra, pues ya me tendré que cagar más en todo lo cagable.
Pero solo por lo que hice en el Chelsea,
ya puede irse a tercera división con el subpróximo equipo,
que se ganó mi respeto para siempre.
Y en una entrevista, era un podcast español en Cataluña,
con varios periodistas catalanes, no recuerdo ahora,
ya lo siento por no poder citarlo,
le preguntan a Guardiola el equipo más difícil
que le había tocado jugar en su vida.
Y hablaba...
Es verdad que lo dijo.
Y hablaba del Chelsea de Tomás Tügel, que más decía,
era un equipo que se cerraba mucho,
que luego tenía también mucha amplitud y que luego era muy largo,
porque Werner Haversmaut te hacía en el equipo muy largo.
Entonces, Guardiola te decía que era el equipo más difícil
con el que se había enfrentado.
Tenía un talentazo defensivo ese equipo.
Compensaba con...
Thiago Silva, Azpilicueta, Rodriér.
No tenía demasiado gol,
no tenía un grandísimo goleador, por eso.
Jorginho fue...
Lo de Lukaku era perfecto.
No entiendo por qué eso no salió bien.
Fue el máximo goleador del Premier League, eh, Jorginho.
Pero tenía un talentazo defensivo.
Hicieron del orden y la disciplina un auténtico placer para ellos.
Disfrutaban en los partidos en los que sentían que eran una formación romana, macho.
Y ahí no pasaba nadie.
Y eso hay que apreciarlo también.
Y creo que en el momento infravaloramos un poco a sus defensas.
Thiago Silva se ha demostrado como una auténtica leyenda del fútbol.
Azpilicueta es uno de los jugadores españoles más infravalorados de la historia.
Akel Rich James.
Y, bueno, y Rüdiger, su salto ha sido luego liderar la defensa del Real Madrid
hasta que se alejó una vital.
Así que bueno.
Y ha ganado la Champions al final.
Pero...
¿Qué iba a decir de...?
Que Túgel es un técnico normalito.
Que se encuentra el Chelsea.
No, bueno, eso no...
Bueno.
Impopular.
Es impopular.
Aunque depende de quién preguntes también, entiendo, eh.
Yo que sé.
O sea, es que...
Es otro de esos debates que hay gente que odia a Túgel.
Bueno, sé que es un estilo que no entra por ahí a la ojo mucho.
Letárgico Otis nos lo deja en Discord.
Inglaterra no es ni ha sido nunca una selección de primer nivel mundial.
Está más cerca a nivel de Suiza o Dinamarca que Alemania o Italia.
Dejor de ser impopular es un dato.
De verdad lo digo.
O sea, Ale...
Esa Inglaterra es una selección...
Mira, en...
Soccernomics, que parece que es un libro al que hablo en todos estos vídeos
de poplírios impopulares, lo analizan.
Inglaterra lleva siendo toda la vida una selección top 10 nivel mundial.
Top 10 no que entre en el top 10, sino que es directamente la décima o la undécima.
Y eso te acerca mucho más a una Dinamarca que a una Alemania o a una Italia
que tienen cuatro mundiales.
Sí, yo creo que aquí a lo mejor lo que...
La percepción general, lo que tiene más...
No iría distorsionado, pero lo que influye más a la hora de pensar siempre
en una de las selecciones top es que luego la selección inglesa
tienen sus filas a varios futbolistas que han sido absolutamente protagonistas
en equipos ingleses que no solo a nivel nacional,
también a nivel internacional han brillado.
Quiero decir, la selección inglesa no fue capaz de juntar
a Lampard, Scholes o Gerrard...
Y Beckham.
Y Beckham, pero quiere decir que son jugadores
que no tenían nada que mostrarle a Europa,
porque cuando salieron también al escenario europeo,
demostraron que no solo eran jugadores muy buenos dentro de su isla,
que también en el escenario europeo han sido campeones
y jugadores de primerísimo nivel, incluso en votaciones como el balón de oro,
por mucho de lo que ustedes no ganan a ninguno.
Pero quiero decir que Eitsa creo que es también un poco la percepción
más allá del rendimiento deportivo.
En cuanto al rendimiento deportivo estoy de acuerdo.
Lo único que han ganado es un mundial en el 66.
Es que han ganado el mundial en el 66, cuéntenme ahí.
Y si le preguntas a un Escoces, hicieron trampa porque la bola entró.
Claro, es que...
Pero a lo que voy es que creo que la percepción tiene más que ver
con los jugadores que vemos normalmente en la plantilla.
Y los jugadores que vemos normalmente en la plantilla,
excepto alguna generación dorada de una Dinamarca o una Suecia,
normalmente son claramente mejores que los de esas selecciones.
Y por eso tenemos esa percepción.
El problema es que deportivamente nunca han sabido
conjugar ese talento con el éxito.
El jugador inglés es de los mejores del mundo a nivel histórico.
Top 5 o top 6, donde hay que disponer.
La selección inglesa no está cerca.
Mira, una cosa muy rápida.
¿Sabes cómo explicaban también por qué pasaba eso?
Una de las razones que había Soccernomics era por lo poco
que habían jugado los jugadores ingleses históricamente en Europa,
en competiciones europeas.
Es decir, que jugar un mundial, al final también es estar un mes
con tus compañeros, estar fuera de tu casa,
hacer stage apartados, hacer pre-tempos...
O sea, estar un mes que no ves mucho ni a tu familia ni a tus amigos.
Simplemente estás con 20, 25, 30 tíos todo el rato,
jugando en diferentes campos de Europa, etcétera.
Y como los jugadores ingleses tradicionalmente han estado
siempre en Inglaterra, no se llevan mucho fuera,
claro, la diferencia de experiencia europea que tenían
selecciones como Suiza era superior a la de selecciones como Inglaterra,
porque al estar en todos los equipos del mundo son gente acostumbrada
a jugar por toda Europa y competición europea.
Y eso era una de las razones por las cuales para el inglés era un shock
tan grande el tener que irse un mes a Alemania,
porque mucha gente de la selección inglesa no había jugado en Alemania
en su vida.
No había ni France Champions.
Claro.
Puebe interesante.
Es esta salchicha.
Sernán de Zbarná dice, el nivel de la Premier está bajando,
cada vez hay partidos más mediocres,
incluso entre los equipos del Big Six,
para la muestra al Arsenal City la semana pasada.
Un peñazo importante.
Bueno, no estoy nada de acuerdo.
El nivel de la Premier League creo que cada vez es más alto,
porque dentro de los top 3, top 4, top 5 plantillas de Europa
hay ahora mismo dos o tres equipos ingleses,
y creo que la clase media de la Premier League
tiene un talento que no ves en ninguna clase media del resto de las ligas.
Es decir, el Forrest, el Villa, el Newcastle también tienen que ser clase media,
porque el Big Six ya es un top 6.
Forrest, Palace, Villa, Newcastle son equipos cada vez más competitivos
y son equipos que hacen que el nivel de la liga suba.
Otra cosa es que los partidos sean más o menos divertidos,
que eso no tiene que ver con el nivel.
Un partido de tercera división puede ser más divertido que la final de la Champions League,
y hay más nivel en la final de la Champions League.
El dinero atrae al talento, como es evidente,
la Premier League es la liga con mayor dinero para invertir en toda Europa.
Es un estilo, además, objetivamente diferente y más intenso,
ya no solo por la sensación viendo los partidos, sino por los puros datos.
Hace poco, os insisto, que vi una gráfica de Sky Sports
que lo que reflejaba es la cantidad de acciones en alta intensidad
y la repetición de esfuerzos respecto a otras ligas,
que no quiere decirme que sea ni mejor ni peor,
pero a mí es un estilo de fútbol que me divierte más,
porque creo que hay más ida y vuelta,
que los partidos están más abiertos a romperse en la Premier League.
Otra vez vuelvo a lo mismo, no es que lo diga yo,
es también preguntándole a entrenadores españoles
qué han estado en ambos lados, se lo he escuchado por ejemplo
decir a Andonira Ola, que es una liga en la que hay mucho más
paso rápido de un área a otra que en España.
Buenísima entrevista en esa la que lo dijo Andonira Ola.
No es una crítica necesaria a otros estilos de fútbol,
simplemente lo que me gusta a mí,
pero por tanto, con todo esto concluido,
que a mí no me parece que sea una liga peor,
de hecho cada vez está asentando más su dominio económico
y por tanto la atracción de talento.
Esto además se junta con una apertura definitiva
ya a estas alturas del cuento hacia el fútbol europeo.
Liverpool no tiene ningún inglés.
No hay más que ver lo que pasa con el Liverpool,
en el once ahora mismo no hay casi chavales locales del Liverpool,
porque si no es por Curtis Jones no salvas esa papeleta,
que no digo que esto tampoco es una crítica al Liverpool,
así está evolucionando la Premier.
Y luego, lo del Arsenal Manchester City,
pues es que son justo dos entrenadores que normalmente intentan anularse
porque se conocen exageradamente bien,
pero yo que sé, también vimos hace nada 6 goles en un Arsenal Manchester City,
verdad que mal repartidos porque 5 eran para un lado,
igual que también hemos visto grandes victorias del City.
Es que me parece que...
A mí me hace la sensación con la Premier que,
cuando hay una jornada de 0-0, qué aburría la Premier League,
y luego cuando hay jornadas de muchos goles,
es que no defienden a nadie la Premier League,
entonces claro, el argumento siempre gana,
pero esto vale para cualquier liga entonces.
Que el nivel no tiene que ver con lo divertido,
que pueda ser luego un partido.
Pero me parece que eso sea por un término económico,
es que lo estamos viendo en todas las ligas,
a la mínima que emerge un talento,
mínimamente que marque las diferencias en una liga,
se lo lleva la Premier, tiene esa capacidad.
Aprovecho para hacer spam,
porque este vídeo lo va a ver mucho más gente que aquí hicimos,
pero por aquí dejamos un vídeo explicando
por qué la Premier League ficha...
Bueno, es la liga que más fiche,
porque la Premier League tiene tanto dinero,
que igual a alguno le puede interesar,
si le ha parecido curiosa nuestra respuesta.
Slot Machine Ball dice,
si hacemos un ranking de los más grandes de Inglaterra,
el Arsenal aún es tercero,
pero está más cerca de ser rebasado por el Chelsea y City,
que alcanzará al United y al Liverpool.
Rotundamente sí.
Al final me parece que en un ranking de grandeza,
hay que medir mucho los títulos de liga,
United y Liverpool tienen 20, Arsenal tiene 13,
City tiene 10, Chelsea tiene 6.
En Champions League, o títulos europeos en general,
el Arsenal solo tiene una recopa,
Chelsea y City es más grande en Europa que el Arsenal.
Sí, estoy de acuerdo.
No hay más.
O sea, el Arsenal necesita una era dorada y gloriosa como pocas
para estar más cerca de United y de Arsenal
que de quien está por detrás.
Oscar Cebre, Jamie Vardy ha sido mejor que otros grandes delanteros
de las épocas doradas de la Premier,
como Dropba, Van Persie o Fernando Torres.
Eh...
Mi respuesta es...
que sí.
Te estoy viendo, para mí es más que Dropba,
para mí es más que Van Persie.
Contextos completamente diferentes.
Me da exactamente igual.
El único con el que tengo alguna duda más
es por el nivel Prime de Fernando Torres.
Creo que el nivel Prime de Fernando Torres
puede ser mejor que el de Vardy.
Miro toda la carrera en la Premier League.
Pero...
Ya está, con Jamie Vardy me da igual que suene a Sacrilegio, de verdad.
O sea, es un futbolista que he conseguido lo imposible,
que no vamos a ver nada ni parecido.
Estoy prácticamente seguro de que me moriré sin ver nada
como lo que ya he visto con el Leicester.
Ninguno de los mencionados ha enfrentado un contexto
tan desfavorable como el de Jamie Vardy,
y eso que Jamie Vardy llegó a estar en equipos con una inversión fuerte,
que luego el Leicester también se la pega.
Por eso, nada comparable a equipos en los que estaban Dropba, Van Persie
y Fernando Torres.
Y es que además me parece que luego tuvo,
más allá de sus éxitos puntuales, una consistencia extraordinaria.
Ser la bota de oro más veterana de la historia de la Premier,
viniendo... ya ni siquiera han ido viniendo a donde venías,
que también me parece que es como para valorarlo.
Pero desde que entras en la Premier hasta que te vas,
tienes una carrera que...
Yo no tengo problema en ponerlo por encima de esos tres,
porque es que es... de verdad.
La pregunta con Vardy más bien es,
hacer el juego este de ¿con quién te quedas?
Porque creo que os llevaréis un susto con la E.
La E de jugadores que pongo por debajo de Jamie Vardy.
Creo que Jamie Vardy, hay una mala concepción
de que es una especie de One Season Wonder.
O sea, de que es un futbolista que se salió con el Leicester...
Esa concepción no es posible.
Pero la bota de oro, que mucha gente sí que no lo sabe,
la bota de oro no la gana el año que gana la Premier.
La bota de oro la gana en la 19-20, creo que es, o la 20-21.
La gana mucho más tarde, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco años más tarde.
O sea, después de salirse en la 15-16 y ganar la Liga,
gana la bota de oro después de tres, cuatro años.
Es un futbolista que desde que llegó al Leicester y ganó la Liga,
superó los 15 goles en casi todas sus temporadas.
No sé si tienen eso los datos.
Estaba mirando que en el año que se mantienen milagrosamente
la 14-15 después de subir el Champions, el marca cinco goles nada más.
Y a partir de ahí, 24 goles en la temporada que gana en la Liga.
Que no es bota de oro.
Trece goles en la siguiente, 23 goles en la siguiente,
todas temporadas de Premier League, 18 goles en la siguiente,
23 goles en la siguiente, 17 goles en la siguiente, 17 otra vez.
Luego baja a tres goles, te lo perdonamos, Jamie Vardy,
18 en Champions para subir al equipo y se marcha.
En su última temporada con más años que un bosque con nueve goles.
Es increíble, tío.
Es que no...
Insisto, con un contexto que es el Leicester City,
un club que incluso lo que te decía de no la inversión y tal cual...
Bueno, sea el Leicester City que luego acaba ganando la FA Cup
y que acaba dándose paseos por Europa,
no se entiende si lo que consiguió Vardy junto a todo su equipo.
Y terminamos con la de Rasinho, que dice,
las copas deberían de dar entrada directa a la Champions.
Así haces que todavía haya más interés por ganarla
y la Liga de Campeones lleva más campeones.
Molaría.
Entiendo, cuando dice copas, es copas en general
y en Inglaterra eso sería la FA Cup.
El ganador de la Copa de la Liga no puede ir a la Champions League.
Pues me gustaría, pero...
Me gustaría.
Sí, en contra de la deriva que ha tomado ahora el fútbol
y que en el fondo tanto por el nuevo fórmato de la Champions League
como los nuevos criterios de clasificación
está construido para que los grandes tengan protegido su estatus,
no que no entren nuevos nombres en la ecuación,
este año que sé, el milagro lo ha conseguido el Kira Talmati,
pero está hecho para que los grandes tengan más protegido que nunca su puesto,
a no ser que haya descalabros como el del Manchester United.
Y a eso responde que entre en el 5,
que luego haya una fase play-off posterior a la fase de Liga.
Bueno, que pasa en 24...
A febrero llegan 24-36.
Pero mira, a mí por ejemplo me gustaría más que entrar
al campeón de la FA Cup que el quinto.
Lo que pasa es que también, no nos engañemos,
la mayor parte de las veces la FA Cup la gana uno de los grandes,
porque así está repartido el... ahora mismo fue el inglés.
Aquí hay que entender que el ganador de Copa va a la Europa League
porque esto fue cuando en la... creo que en el 77-98 la UEFA junta,
Copa la UEFA y Recopa,
entonces el ganador de la Copa del Rey o la FA Cup antes iba la Recopa
y ahora va la Copa de la UEFA.
A mí me gustaría que de Inglaterra fueran tres,
porque ahora estamos dando por hecho siempre lo del quinto,
pero para que la gente tenga dudas, no es quinto, es una plaza extra.
Si es a la Liga, a la Serie, a la Bundesliga, a la Premier, será el quinto.
Pero imagínate que fueran tres vía Liga, uno vía FA Cup
y ya el extra que sea el cuarto o el quinto en caso de que la FA Cup
lo gane uno de los que ya hemos mencionado.
Me parecería que sería interesante y sobre todo ya no en Inglaterra,
pero que en otros...
Joder, es que en España llega la final y la han ganado al Eticlub,
la ha ganado la Real Sociedad, llega la final el Mallorca,
ha ganado la final a Osasuna,
es un premio que ya es plantarte en la Champions League y creo que...
Que eres campeón.
Es que eres campeón.
Joder, eres un campeón nacional.
Vale que no eres el campeón del campeonato nacional de Liga,
pero eres el campeón nacional de la competición del KO.
Es que me parece que es un honor enorme que con los últimos años
ha ido perdiendo peso y ser campeón de la Copa del Rey o de la FA Cup
es la hostia.
De hecho...
La hostia eres a tu manera el campeón español.
Entiendo, eh, que el campeón inglés que gana la Premier
y el campeón español es el que gana la Liga.
Pero has sido el mejor equipo de tu país en enfrentamientos...
No, en enfrentamientos eliminatorios.
Y eso me parece un honor que pasear el resto de tu vida.
Y que merece también un puesto así de grande
como sería entrar en Champions.
Ahora, ya os aviso, el fútbol ya está montado de una manera...
Que no, esto no lo vamos a ver.
Si queréis una opinión popular es la Champions que yo haría.
Pero creo que además la UEFA históricamente lo premiaba mucho.
La UEFA tenía dos competiciones y las dos eran para campeones.
La Copa de campeones, la Copa Europa, que era la de campeones de Liga,
y la Recopa, que era para campeones de Copa.
Tenías mucho peso.
Ahora ya...
O si fuera a la Recopa no la tratarían bien.
No la tratarían bien.
Ahora mismo en el sistema actual...
No tiene sentido en el sistema actual.
...acabaría siendo un fracaso.
Pero en mi Champions League jugaría en 16 equipos, ya lo sabéis.
Nada.
Hasta aquí llegan las opiniones impopulares.
Y he dejado yo la mía, que quizás es la más impopular,
para el final un día lo debatiremos.
Un día...
¿Sabes qué podemos hacer?
Llegar al día.
Que nosotros pongamos 5 o 6 opiniones impopulares
en una caja escritas en un papel y vayamos sacándolas.
Y cuando salen tiene que ir uno a defenderla.
A ver si consigue convencer a los otros dos.
A ver quién coge las de Jesús.
No, las de Jesús la defienden.
Jesús tiene una.
Y no sabemos ninguno cuál es.
Y tenemos que descubrir...
Yo creo que la opinión impopular de Jesús,
yo me las imagino muy secas.
Tipo...
El Chelsea es una mierda.
Luego otro papel.
El Liverpool es una basura.
Así y todo.
Y listo.
Podría parir a toda la línea.
Y de repente diría...
Jesús es también muy de decir cosas.
El Leeds es el equipo más grande de Inglaterra.
No, si eres del Forrest no.
Si eres del Forrest no está prohibido.
Pero desoltarlo.
Bueno amigos, muchas gracias por aportarnos
vuestras opiniones impopulares.
Algunas más impopulares que otras.
Y os dejamos que en comentarios despotriquéis
desde el cariño, el respeto y la concordia.
Y nos vemos en el próximo vídeo de este nivel.
Y a OPA el aerodeportivo, ¿no?
OPA.